ce n'erano così tante ma così tante che
ho dovuto per forza fare la seconda
parte donne amiche ragazze soltanto per
oggi in esclusiva per voi la pagina più
irritante dell'intero emisfero boreale
[Musica]
allora ragazze come ho fatto a
dimenticare l'anno scorso video come ho
potuto come ho usato aveva quando un
ragazzo ci risponde a un papiro messaggi
rocorda qualsiasi cosa
un occhiolino è proprio lì che non ci
sentiamo presi per i fondelli
ma stai scherzando cioè tu pensi avere
pure a ventimiglia possibilità commesse
in vino carino l'occhiolino è out
proprio non deve esistere per me non è
no
è strano
ma non pensare che l'occhiolino sia
l'unico appartenente alla categoria
mister vendo per il culo non osare e non
permette di meglio da tutte le dita
perché ci sono anche loro c'è il
sorrisone di cortesia più finto di tempe
scenario ad una fase veramente geologo e
in sopportare capirci ha sondato
pensarci la pelle d'oca fa schifo c'è
anche il sorrisino perchè la faccina
sorridente di sopra e di sotto non ce
l'hai sventato dalla nascita questo solo
il vino anche fittissimo numero dei mai
mangiare tutta la tua vita
e poi c'è ma che cos'è l'ape maia che
cosa mi rappresenta
cioè tu mi rispondi messaggio così io
che cosa devo capire i problemi e
ricordate quando vi parlavo del famoso
detto woods il che balla pecchia to move
ieri ed era subito chalet quieto molto
bene
c'è un'altra e logiche e sempre
nell'ambito ghetto mood che è quello
file on morrone pieno di soldi il pai
riccone oltre invece sono anche tutte
queste paghiamo a metà e fai lo
splendido c'è qualcosa che non quadra
e qui signor signora il rullo di tamburi
è il cuore in tutti i sensi del video
ed è in questo momento più di annuncio
l'uscita di un nuovo film che si chiama
50 sfumature di cuori nelle emoji eco
ragazzi perché fatte questa fatica
allucinata e avviarci un cuore ufficiale
il cuore ufficiale è rosso rosso dai
tempi di adamo ed eva ecco perché perché
di rimandare
uno di questi colori che cos'è il mondo
di patty il cuore giallo cosa vuoi dirmi
che sei geloso giallo come la gelosia
perché verde verde speranza cioè nero un
presagio di morte blu che cos'è un cuore
estivo marino cioè per me è
definitivamente cento per cento
come ricordate la scossa molto parlato
del mood fai la brava con l'angioletto
l'aureola ecco era tutto molto vario
tutto molto evangelico ma infatti oggi
vuole parlare dell'opposto quindi per il
ragazzo che vuole sentirsi diavolo
dentro il diavoletto stronzetto il dio
in pugno stai sulle spine ma c'è ma che
cosa mi rappresenta questa cosa cioè
perché me la mandi pensi di fare il
piccolo stessa cosa per mister
maliziosetto cioè un emoji che si può
usare travi che tra amici ma se stiamo
portante della mani ma che cosa vuoi
farmi capire cosa che ci stai facendo
pensiero è un doppio senza del tutto
molto yeah perché
ma passiamo ad un'altra categoria la
categoria di quei ragazzi che amano
stupire chiamano le sorprese vedi tu
stai parlando del più e del meno con lui
è niente se ne esce con uno dei 200 mila
animali che ci sono tra le mogli possono
essere i più svariati il pesce palla il
gamberetto il cammello cosa fai studi
veterinaria e poi parlare dei tuoi
interessi dei tuoi studi oppure lavori
in un centro zoologico ecco non lo so
forse una risposta il fatto che noi
ragazze siamo messe di fronte veramente
alle più svariate opzioni cioè non
riusciamo a capire perché si sta
parlando di a e tutele chico di d'animo
net e parlando sempre dei ragazzi ci
vogliono stupire invece di un mazzo di
rose le mose
ma ecco molto sovrannaturale molto
khyber ci piace comunque sapere che
avete rivisto logici concludiamo questo
video in bellezza con cui diamo alcuna
nota romantica
con delle mogli che ci lasciano sempre
senza parole è quasi sempre dallo schifo
solo queste ci siamo passate tutte lo so
nel momento difficile perché comunque
chiudiamo completamente i ponti con chi
ce li manda e libertiamo l'ha votato su
tutti i social e momento difficile ma mi
sarò vicino perché l'uomo che chiamando
una di queste è un uomo che danno non
riceverà neanche un emoticon merito
avete qualcosa da aggiungere
io direi che parlano da sole eccoci
arrivati alla fine del video secondo me
con la prima parte la seconda parte ho
elencato tutte secondo ci sono tutte
quelle proprio che non ci devono inviare
se video vi è piaciuto come sempre
mettete like e iscrivetevi alla mia
pagina siamo sempre di più grazie mille
diamo e niente seguitemi anche sugli
altri social facebook
instagram musicali mentre renzi che read
this item quella roba lì
[Musica]